alrighty folks so i am here to recap and
review the season four finale of
yellowstone yellowstone of course one of
the most watched shows on tv it's
produced created written by taylor
sheridan he of course has his own taylor
sheridan verse he's most famous for
doing movies like sicario and wind river
and hello or high water he also has
three shows simultaneously running which
is totally crazy his yellowstone 1883
and mayor of kingstown yellowstone is
the most popular of the shows as we'll
discuss i don't think it's the best of
those shows we'll get to all of that and
more in just one moment first this video
is brought to you by our friends at
expressvpn
okay so i've been watching yellowstone
since it first came out and before it
was kind of a thing mainly because i
will watch any show that has guns and
people in cowboy hats it doesn't matter
what it is it sort of had a slow build
to become a thing and now it is the most
watched television show in america
mainly because it's got kevin costner
and cowboys doing cowboy things and
people like that sort of thing it also
happens to be a show that is horribly
written i mean it makes no sense
whatsoever there is no internal logic to
it this season it just fell apart
completely so the original setup for
yellowstone for folks who haven't
watched the show and spoiler alert there
will be spoilers the original setup of
the show is that john dutton is kevin
costner and john dutton has the dutton
ranch right it's in montana it's this
giant chunk of land that has been
carried forward over the course of
generations and there is sort of this
three-way conflict between a native
american tribe which feels that they
were the original owners of the land
before the duttons came there and then
there is the dutton family which is
trying to maintain the ranch and then
there are these developers who are
coming in and they alternatively want to
build a hotel or a casino or an airport
that is the first season and it's kind
of interesting because even though it's
really purple and a lot of people are
getting shot randomly in montana which
would probably draw some national news
coverage more people have been murdered
in montana over the course of the show
than actually live in montana in real
life the bodies are stacked like
cordwood in montana according to the
show
but the basic idea of the show is that
john dutton was a man who was willing to
do what was necessary in order to
preserve the ranch with the help of his
sort of main man in crime rip was his
adopted son and who happens to be just a
super badass who's just killing people
and throwing them down hills and such
right and then the entire ranch is run
sort of like a mafia business was the
original concept of the show
everybody who comes in has to get a
giant brand on them with the yellowstone
and you have to be there for life and
you have to be loyal and it's supposed
to be sort of like sopranos set in the
west well pretty quickly it became clear
that taylor sheridan was too in love
with john dutton's character to allow
that to happen so now kevin costner is
basically just an out and out
white-hated hero everything that he does
is wonderful and rip who is sort of
a brutal murderer but also kind of
awesome now rip is also a saint who only
does really good things and if he does a
bad thing it's to somebody who's totally
bad we know is bad the original
tripartite setup has completely
disappeared at this point the native
american storyline which was the
conflict between the native american
tribe and the ranch which was supposed
to be exacerbated by the fact that
john's son casey has sort of a split
life where he is john's son served in
the military but then came back and
married monica who's a member of the
tribe this was supposed to create all
sorts of internal dissension and
conflict casey has basically been
marginalized thomas rainwater who's the
leader of the tribe and sort of a clever
political operator he's been completely
marginalized even the developer
storyline has been completely
marginalized right there's a big
corporation called market equities which
should just be called big corporation
big inc that's supposed to be investing
in the land wants to buy the land wants
to remake it into an airport and all
this and they're the bad guys right even
they've been marginalized so this season
is just a complete mess
it's a complete mess like all of the
character-driven sort of conflict has
been completely ripped away right one of
the sons is jamie jamie is this supposed
to be smooth political operator who also
is apparently some sort of sociopath it
turns out that he was adopted his dad
was a murderer and john just had this
habit of taking in kids apparently and
so jamie was supposed to have all this
internal conflict and he was going to
run for governor against his father and
then that all went by the wayside that's
all the lead-up to this season okay last
season season three of yellowstone ended
with everyone getting shot or blown up
everyone casey gets shot jon gets shot
repeatedly beth gets blown up by a bot
there's a bomb like a foot from her
that's the end of season three and
you're like whoa who lived who died man
this is gonna change the face of
yellowstone forever
nope season four five minutes in
everybody's fine casey's healed up he's
fine john shot 97 times he is totally
fine beth had a bomb literally blow up
next to her and she apparently walked
out of the building
fairly unscathed with a few scars and
scrapes and just slice up a cigarette
and she's totally fine as well beth is
supposed to be sort of the wild card
character who doesn't like the ranch but
she's kind of loyal to her dad
and she's a complete dissolute mess well
now she's
monogamous and in love with rip and they
are going to get married and all that
that's very nice okay so the story line
for this season was supposed to be who
tried to kill them and the question was
was it jamie so you figured the entire
thing is going to be jamie who has been
at odds with the family and he's now
found his actual natural father and his
father sort of manipulating him is jamie
going to side against the family and
this is going to be the conflict right
that's what you think the conflict is
going to be in the first episode it
turns out nope it turns out that's not
the chief conflict at all in fact there
is no chief conflict each one of these
characters has a bizarre separate
storyline that makes no sense at all and
again we're gonna get to the finale
because the writing is just abysmal in
the finale i mean just bad just out now
bad so here are the character arcs for
the season john dutton's job is he he's
gonna run for governor to stop jamie
from being governor is that the main
story line nope the main story line with
john is that he's stupid an
environmental terrorist played by piper
parabo who hasn't been in a thing since
i think coyote ugly in 1972. so close
he's shipping her she's an environmental
terrorist we have no idea why he's
interested in her or why he would be
interested in her and uh his entire
storyline this season is he's stupping
her and then she goes to jail for a
short period of time that's his
storyline this season then there's
beth's storyline this season which
basically was she adopts a child and
then alienates the child and is mean to
the child i don't want those
things
i i don't know beth is sort of supposed
to be a girl boss who's good at things
but she's really bad at everything and
apparently good business strategy in
yellowstone is walking into rooms
in very low-cut dresses and then
sexually harassing everybody inside
including random secretaries like there
is no worse job in america than to be a
secretary who has to talk to beth dutton
there's no evidence she's good at
anything but apparently she's really
good at business okay but she's this
uber uber-rich billionaire's daughter
who lives on the most beautiful ranch in
all of america and she's like abusing
the minimum wage employees and she does
this to everyone she does this to
everyone so her entire story line this
year is just being mean to people just
randomly being mean to people okay then
there's casey's storyline which
apparently just involves him dealing
with the fallout from the fact that in
the last episode of season three his son
tate had to shoot a dude and the season
starts with his son experiencing
post-traumatic stress disorder so strong
that he's literally hiding under the bed
for hours at a time this however is
resolved in the first couple episodes of
the season when casey literally goes
into a room looks at his son under the
bed and says you need to come out from
under the bed you're fine and the kid
goes okay which is how you solve
post-traumatic stress disorder in
yellowstone apparently but monica the
mom is still really pissed about all of
this and so she wants to move back to
the reservation so they do
and that's the storyline jamie's story
line is that he wants to run for
governor with the help of his derelict
natural father who tried to plot the
murder of the rest of his family except
that it becomes pretty clear
very soon that jaime has no shot at
being governor because his dad is
running for governor we don't even get
them running against each other because
the script immediately forecloses jamie
from running by pointing out that oh
yeah his natural father is a murderer
who murdered his mother and also jamie
is super corrupt those are the actual
story lines this season guys oh what i
forgot one story line there's a hand at
the ranch whose name is jimmy jimmy is
an incredibly dull character no one
cares about jimmy his entire story going
back to season one is that he was
basically a career criminal who ended up
being given the choice to work at the
ranch or to go to jail he works at the
ranch he breaks his back twice rodeoing
and then he is sent down to another
ranch the four sixes down in texas where
he learns to be a cowboy by the way
that's all set up for the spin-off that
they're doing of the four sixes in texas
so we have that whole story line that no
one cares about okay so this leads up to
the season finale so what happens in the
season finale of yellowstone and the
answer is kinda nothing we'll get some
more of this in just one moment first a
few decades ago private citizens used to
be largely that private what changed
well the internet think about all the
things you browse searched for watched
tweeted now imagine all that data being
crawled through collected aggregated by
third parties into a permanent public
record your record having your private
life exposed for others to see that was
something that celebrities used to have
to worry about but nobody else now
everyone is a public figure to keep my
data private when i go online i turn to
expressvpn did you know there are
hundreds of data brokers out there and
their sole business is to buy and sell
your data the worst part is they don't
have to tell you who they're selling it
to or get your consent one of those data
points is your ip address data
harvesters use your ip to uniquely
identify you and your location with
expressvpn my connection gets rerouted
through an encrypted server my ip
address is masked every time i turn
expressvpn on i'm given a random ip
address shared by other expressvpn
customers that makes it really hard for
third parties to identify me and harvest
my data the best part is how easy
expressvpn is to use like check this out
okay so i just open up this phone you
can see there is the expressvpn logo now
it's open i hit it
doink it's connected and now
my internet activity is protected it is
that simple if like me you believe your
data is your business secure yourself
with the number one rated vpn on the
market visit expressvpn.com ben yt and
get three extra months for free that's
expressvpn.com
ben yt go to
expressvpn.combnyt to learn more
so let me begin with casey he goes out
into the wilderness and he does like a
spirit walk where he doesn't eat or
drink for four days and has visions of a
wolf that is alternatively a very hot
native american woman who's not his wife
that that is the end of his season so
good good on him then there's the end of
john season which is he gets
environmental terrorist lady sentence
reduced from 15 years to like 18 months
that's the end of that and then there is
beth and jamie so beth's storyline in
the last episode is just wild so beth
finds out that the person who put out
the hit and john has known this for a
while was a person who was in prison
right he's sort of a murder broker in
prison for some reason and she decides
that she is going to personally go there
and kill this person we don't know why
we don't know why as one of the richest
and most powerful people in montana she
cannot get somebody inside the prison to
do it which is normally how you would
make something like that happen i would
imagine instead she's personally going
to do this so she's always suspected
that jamie was the person who was behind
the mirror here's her idea of how she's
going to take revenge on the person who
ordered the hits on her family she goes
to walker who is a random dude at the
ranch who also has a criminal record and
she's like tell me about prison he's
like prison it's bad she's like whoa
tell me more he's like well let me tell
you it's really bad but are there
conjugal visits he's like yes sometimes
he's like well how do i get a weapon in
it's like well
you could bring a hairpin
all you really have to do is wear
something low cut and they'll let you
right in with a hairpin and she's like
perfect okay so then this is this story
i'm never gonna get over this she goes
to the prison in a conjugal visit this
hulking giant inmate who is a murderer
who is in prison
for life and he has no boyfriend so he's
had no conjugal visits for like 30 years
okay he walks in to a conjugal visit
room he is alone with beth dutton who is
an attractive woman wearing i kid you
not a negligee because it's a conjugal
visit her plan was
that this man who is at least eight
times her size
and a murderer and maybe a rapist
her plan is she is going to kill him
with a hairpin that is her original plan
i have questions okay then beth proceeds
to ask him about like did he put out the
hit on her family and he is like well i
mean i did but that's what i do for a
living and also i already told this to
that lawyer guy she's like oh my god do
you mean this lawyer dutch takes out her
cell phone it's jamie because the script
is so empty this season every single
episode is filled with 10 minutes of
beth just being terrible to someone so
she's got murder broker in front she
mean to murder broker i get it but she
gives him i kid you it's got to be it
feels like a four-hour lecture about why
he's bad and will live a bad life he
knows he's in prison
in prison bad stuff happens right so she
gives him a lecture about you're in
prison you're gonna be for her for a
hundred years
and i hope you die and then when you do
die you're gonna remember me giving you
this speech okay but it gets better for
bath because beth's next move is that
she's on her way home to the ranch for
some reason she now takes the hair pin
out of her hair which has some symbolic
resonance of some sort because she sees
a priest she forces a priest into her
car at gunpoint brings him back to the
ranch and forces him to perform a
wedding with her in rip in front of her
dad
while she's in her negligee she's got
her surrogate son over here
watching
weird weird way to do a wedding strange
then it gets even better she decides
okay now i have to go confront jamie so
she confronts jamie and she's like you
know
we've got a few choices for you but
there's one choice you should take the
choice that you should take is that you
should shoot your dad your natural dad
he's like okay so he shoots his natural
dad and dumps him down the mountain with
like all the rest of the dutton bodies
right there's like this hill where you
the the law the black train the long
black train you throw people down the
hill okay so jamie shoots his dad after
saying i love you to him and she takes a
video of this and then she's like we own
you jamie we own you well here's the
thing the dutton family has owned jamie
all along they literally covered up
another murder for him two seasons ago
so
what
huh and that's the end of the season
is that everything is hunky-dory we know
that casey has had some sort of spirit
vision with a hot wolf girl thing we
know that john
is not going to be with the
environmental terrorist lady because
she's still in prison
and is still running for governor maybe
we know that jamie is back in the fold
kind of but only because his sister beth
who is the worst person on the show is
blackmailing him but she's happily
married now
somehow
yeah
so bottom line i'll continue to watch
the show because it's a hot mess but
it's it's fun to watch a hot a hot mess
i'm sort of like quasi hate watching it
at this point it needs to be better
written somebody needs to put together a
show bible in which we know before the
season begins which characters are going
to do what and how it all ties together
here's what i would like to see i would
like to see if they're going to continue
with the jamie john dutton thing then we
need to actually see them run against
one another and then the question
becomes how dirty do they want to get in
that race i think that we need more from
beth like she needs more to do so it'd
be kind of fascinating for her to be
alienated from dad and somehow to
rekindle the friendship that she
originally had with jamie we know from
when they were kids that might be sort
of interesting we need to find casey
really stuck between the native american
interests on the show and the and his
father's interests on the show and he's
supposed to sort of bridge both and
figure out how that dynamic works in
other words you know actual plot and
storyline and maybe some characters like
that that would be good i feel like that
is your season 4 recap
and we will see you for the next season
of yellowstone i want to be a cowboy
baby
thanks for tuning in and if you enjoy my
movie and tv show reviews click that
like button and subscribe so you don't
miss out on any of our videos in the
future